ALLEN ARCHULETTA ATKINS
BATES BECKER
GORGEOUS BRADFORD CABRERA
CORTEZ THREE DALLY GOD TORONTO
AT. PLEASE GONZALES GROVE
HERTZBERG WAY SO HER TADO JONES
CAN. FLARED LLEVA THE CHOIR
MELINDA'S MAN- NEW. NIELSEN
PHOTO OF BOTH PAN. ARCHING TINO
ROSS. RUBIO SKINNER NUMBER
WHITE HOUSE SKI WINNER WELL.
GRAHAM SECRETARY WITH THE
MEMBERS AND I'LL JUST BE ON THE
REAL IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RUN
WILL BE LEADING PLAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY SENATOR- CHULBUL
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING AND WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG BY SENATOR. HERTEL SENATOR
BILL. A CHILDREN'S GIVE ME.
THANK YOU. HANTEO HUNTER YO
MEANS CLEAR THE WAY THE LAKOTA
LANGUAGE OF NORTH AMERICAN
PLANES. GOD OF SURPRISES YOU
CALL US FROM THE NEARNESS OF
OUR TRADITIONS TO NEW WAYS OF
BEING HUMAN. FROM THE CAPTIVITY
IS OF OUR CULTURE TO THE
CREATIVE VOICES FOR JUSTICE
FROM THE SMALLNESS OF OUR
HORIZONS TO THE MAGNIFICENCE OF
YOUR VISION FOR A WORLD. CLEAR
THE WAY AND ASK YOUR PEOPLE
THAT WE MIGHT INVITE EACH OTHER
TO FREEDOM AND RENEWED FAITH.
GOT OF SURPRISES YOU CALL US
FROM PRE OCCUPATION WITH OUR
OWN HISTORIES AND HURTS TO
DAILY TASK OF PEACEMAKING. FROM
PRIVILEGE AND PROTOCOL. TO
PARTNERSHIP IN PILGRIMAGE FROM
ISOLATION AND INSULARITY TO
INCLUSIVE COMMUNITY. CLEAR THE
WAY NICER PEOPLE THAT WE MIGHT
INVITE EACH OTHER TO THE
WHOLENESS AND INTEGRITY. HOLY
TRANSFORMING SPIRIT. YOU CALL
US FROM FEAR TO FAITHFULNESS
FROM CLUTTERTO CLARITY FROM A
DESIRE TO CONTROL TO DEEPER
TRUST. FOR THE REFUSAL TO LOVE
TO READINESS TO REFERENCE YOUR
CREATION. CLEAR THE WAY IN US
HERE PEOPLE THAT WE MIGHT ALL
KNOW THE BEAUTY AND POWER OF
PRESERVING EARTH'S FUTURE
GENERATIONS AND THEN.
COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
JUST. IT IS. YES CALL WHEN THE.
WE HAVE THE MOMENT OF FIRMS
REMOTELY GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR
WELCOME. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DRY MESSAGES
FROM THESE WILL BE DOING RED
REPORTS OF WILL BE DEEMED DREAD
AND I'M IN A- MOTIONS GROW. AND.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR THE WEEK OF MAY
THIRD THROUGH SIX TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THEM IN THE COURT.
MEMBERS I KNOW WE'RE ALL VERY
EXCITED TO BE BACK TOGETHER BUT
I'M GOING TO REMIND YOU TO
PLEASE BESOCIALLY DISTANT AND
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION PLEASE TAKE IT OFF
THE FLOOR SO THAT WE CAN DO.
OUR BUSINESS- MEMBERS WE'RE
MOVING ON TO CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE SECOND READING
FILE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SIX NINETY
SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS. THE
SECOND MEETING FILE IS ADOPTED
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS ITEM
SIX AND EIGH WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH FILE ITEM SIX
SENATOR BATES PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS I HAVE THE HONOR J. 2%
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX WHICH IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF A MAN THE
RATE OF COMMISSIONER OF THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL THIS
IS AN HISTORIC MOMENT FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMISSIONER RAY IS
THE FIRST WOMAN TO BE APPOINTED
TO LEAD THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL AS ITS COMMISSIONER SHE
IS THE SECOND AFRICAN AMERICAN
TO BE APPOINTED COMMISSIONER
WELL THOSE ARE NOTABLE FACTS
AND IMPORTANT FROM AN HISTORIC
STANDPOINT. I WANT YOU TO KNOW
WHAT IS MORE IMPORTANT AND
MANTA RAY IS EXCEPTIONAL SHE'S
HIGHLY QUALIFIED HAVING SERVED
IN MANY CAPACITIES THAT CHP
OVER HER THIRTY YEARS OF
SERVICE TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA COMMISSIONER RAY
STARTED AS A CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL OFFICER IN NINETEEN
NINETY AND THREW HER
DETERMINATION SKILLS AND
RESULTS ORIENTED ATTITUDE THE
MISTREATED LEADERSHIP QUALITIES
THAT WOULD PROPEL HER INTO THIS
POSITION. NOT ONLY IS SHE A LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONAL WITH A
TRACK RECORD OF EXEMPLARY
SERVICE AND ACHIEVEMENT SHE IS
ALSO A WONDERFUL ROLE MODEL FOR
YOUNG WOMEN WHO ARE THINKING OF
MAKING A LAW ENFORCEMENT CAREER
NO DOUBT SHE WILL SERVE ALL
CALIFORNIANS WELL AS OUR NEW
COMMISSIONER SHE WAS APPROVED
ON A UNANIMOUS FIVE ZERO VOTE
IN THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE
ON MAY FIFTH. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES MEMBERS REMOVED
DISCUSSION. AND DEBATE SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MY NUMBER I
RIDE AGAINST SUPPORT OF. AMANDA
RATE TO THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY.
HAS STATED MISS RAY HAS AN
EXEMPLARY A CAREER. WITH THE C.
H. P. HE SERVED A THIRTY YEARS
AND- ON THIS DEPARTMENT. BUT
SHE ENTERED THIS DEPARTMENT.
ONLY TO EARN MONEY FOR GRAD
SCHOOL AND WIND UP REALIZING
WHAT A WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY
THIS WAS FOR HER TO BE A ROLE
MODEL NOT ONLY FOR WOMEN BUT
AFRICAN AMERICANS AS WELL. SHE
IS CRITICALLY NEEDED AT THIS
TIME OF GREAT DISTRUST
SPECIALLY IN THE MINORITY
COMMUNITY AS IT RELATES TO OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT. SHE WILL BE A
GREAT BRIDGE BUILDER TO BRING
FORTH TRUST. AND SHE HAS. WILL
HELP NOT ONLY RECRUIT AFRICAN
AMERICANS BUT WOMEN AS WELL HE
WAS THE FIRST DEPUTY FEMALE
COMMANDER OF THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL. AND AGAIN AS
CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS I'M HONORED TO LEND MY
VOICE IN THE CAUCASUS SUPPORT
OF MISS RAY I COMMEND THE
GOVERNOR FOR THIS. FORWARD
THINKING- APPOINTMENT AND FOR
THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR
APPROVING SUCH A WORTHY
INDIVIDUAL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
BRADFORD CENTER GROVE. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I THE
PRIVILEGE ON AND BE ABLE TO ADD
MISS THREE AND- IN COMMISSIONER
RAISED. ONE OF MOST QUALIFIED
PEOPLE THAT I'VE EVER HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY INTERVIEW IN THIS
POSITION. SHE IS LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM GUARDIA SAID
THIRTY YEARS EXPERIENCE THAT
CAME AND SHE JUST STARTED TO-
EARN A LITTLE EXTRA MONEY AND
THEN THIRTY ONE YEARS LATER SHE
STILL SERVING IN THIS
DEPARTMENT. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT SHE SAYS THAT SHE
CAN ACTUALLY RETIRE. YOU'RE
ACTUALLY TIRED WITH HER
RETIREMENT MAKE AS MUCH MONEY
THAT HE'S MAKING NOW BUT SHE
CARES SO DEEPLY ABOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS IT WAS
SERVING YOUR NEEDS HER THAT SHE
IS TAKING ON THIS ROLE AND
RESPONSIBILITY IN THIS.
TUMULTUOUS TIME- ON MY WAY UP
THIS MORNING I STOPPED AND I
DID A SERVICE AT A PEACE
OFFICER'S MEMORIAL WHERE MANY
OFFICERS WERE- GATHER TOGETHER
AND- I MENTIONED ONE OF THE
COMMENTS- WITH- MYSTERY ABOUT.
HER APPOINTMENT AND WHAT IS SHE
GONNA DO ABOUT RELATIONS
BETWEEN THE COMMUNITY AND- LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICE OFFICERS IN
HOW TO BUILD THAT. SHE NEEDED
TO RESPOND ABOUT THE STRATEGIC-
KEY- PORTIONS ARE- AREAS OF THE
SEAS P. WHICH IS ALREADY BEEN
ASSIGNED TO WHERE SHE'S ALREADY
EXCEL THAT WITH GEORGE PROVIDE
LEADERSHIP WITH. SHE WAS VERY-
AMENABLE THIS ONE WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS VERY
FAMILIAR TO BE AMENABLE TO THE
SWING SPACE. AND WHERE WE WOULD
BE RELOCATING AND THIS IN
NOVEMBER AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE WERE ALL SAFE AS WELL- AS
SHE IS AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
GARDENA SAID A- AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN. AND SHE IS THE
FIRST FEMALE WOMAN SHE'S THE
FIRST FEMALE TO BE APPOINTED TO
THIS POSITION I COMMEND THE%
GOVERNOR ON THAT BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY I COMMEND THE
GOVERNOR ASIDE FROM THOSE TWO
ITEMS BECAUSE I THINK WE GET
OFF TRACK AND TALK ABOUT THOSE
THINGS OFTEN. SHE IS THE MOST
QUALIFIED PERSON FOR THIS JOB
AND I DON'T THINK IT HAS
ANYTHING TO DO WITH HER RACE OR
HEARD GENDER I THINK IT'S
BECAUSE SHE IS TOTALLY AND
COMPLETELY QUALIFIED FOR THE
POSITION THAT SHE IS GOING TO
THE SAME SITE. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR EITHER. THANK YOU SENATOR
GROW. MEMBERS ADDITIONAL.
EXCUSE ME DISCO OR DEBATE YES
ROB FOR C. FREEMAN PRESIDENT
DOT THE- GREAT IN PRO OF-
MEETING THE COMMISSIONER AND
THOUSAND AND TWELVE WHEN I WAS
FOR ELECTED TOTHE STATE
SENATOR WAS. OUR COMMANDER CAPT.
IN RIVERSIDE I. THERE IT BECAME
CLEAR TO ME. THAT SHE WAS AN
EXCEPTIONAL. OFFICER SHE DID AN
EXTRAORDINARY JOB IN WESTERN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY IN THE AREAS
THAT SHE WAS IN CHARGE OF I
COULD TELL THAT HER TROOPS.
RESPECTED HER HIGHLY AND SO DID
THE COMMUNITY THAT SHE SERVES I
KNEW SHE WAS ON A LOCKET FOR
BIGGER AND BETTER THINGS AND
I'M JUST ABSOLUTELY DELIGHTED.
THAT THE GOVERNMENT SELECTED
HER AS THE COMMISSIONER FOR A
COUPLE OF CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL AND I LOOK FORWARD. TO
TESTING AND I VOTE ON THIS
APPOINTMENT THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SENATOR
ROBB MEMBERS FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
THAT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA OR HI AT KINS. HI
BABIES. HI BACKER I PORGES OR
HI BRADFORD. HI ABOUT YOUR OWN.
CORTESE I DOLLAR. HI THE- I
TORONTO. FIVE EIGHT. I PLEASE I
DOLLARS I GROW. FIVE HURTS FOR
FIVE WITH SO HI TADO HI JOAN I
CAN LOG HI LEHRER. HI LLEVA I
WIRE. I MELINDA'S I MEN I
NEWMAN I NEED. I A SHOW OF BOTH
HI CAN HI FOR TWENTY. HI HI
RUBIO. HI SKINNER HI AMBERG HI
WHAT CASKEY FIVE WINNER I WILL
HI ONE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
MEMBERS WERE NOW MOVING TO FILE
ITEM EIGHT SENATOR BATES. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF KATHERINE
HOPKINS AND RUDOLPH REVEALED
FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE BOATING
AND WATERWAYS COMMISSION MISS
HAWKINS IS THE CALIFORNIA
ORGANIZER FOR OUTDOOR ALLIANCE
IN MR MURRAY- IS THE DIRECTOR
OF STATE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SAN DIEGO. THESE
APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED IN THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON MAY FIFTH ON
A FIVE ZERO VOTE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BUILT THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES MEMBERS. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THAT FROM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS HI BASED.
HI BECKER HI FORGES. BRADFORD I
HAVE A I DON'T. COURTESY HI
DOLLY. HI TODD. HI THERE ARE SO
HI ADNAN HI GLAZER MY
CONDOLENCES HIGH GROWTH. HI
HURTS BERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA FIVE MCCOY- HI
MELINDA'S HI ADNAN. I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN HI A SHOW OF BOTH. HI
CAN. FIVE FOURTEEN TINA. FIVE
ROTH HI RUBIO FIVE SKINNER I AM
BERG BY WACO SKI I WINNER I
WILL HI PLEASE CALL WE HAVE
SOME MEMBERS. BORJA BY ADAM
FIVE THREE SIX NINE ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO THE SENATE THIRD READING
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM SEVENTEEN SIR CORTESE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT ON
FILE I'M SEVENTEEN VERY GOOD
MAN SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL SEVEN EIGHTY BY
SENATOR CORTEZ HE AN ACT
RELATING TO LOCAL FINANCE.
SENDER CORTESE. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS TODAY I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT S. P. SEVEN EIGHTY. A
BILL THAT IMPLEMENTS CHANGES TO
BOTH ENHANCE INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICTS HE- IF
THESE LAW AND COMMUNITY
REVITALIZATION PERSON AUTHORITY
ALSO KNOWN AS- C. R. I. A.'S-
THOSE LAWS ARE THERE TO HELP
CITIES AND COUNTIES USE TOOLS
TO FINANCE LOCAL DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS. SINCE THE ELIMINATION
OF REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES IN
TWENTY ELEVEN. THE LEGISLATURE
ENACTED SEVERAL TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING TOOLS TO SUPPORT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. TO ADDRESS
OUR HOUSING CRISIS HE I. F.
D.'S IN C. R. A.'S HAMMERS AS
TOOLS THAT ALLOW LOCAL AGENCIES
TO USE A TAX INCREMENT OF
PARTICIPATING ENTITIES TO FUND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECTS. HOWEVER THE
MINIMAL UPTAKE. OF BOTH III OF
TEAS AND C. R. A.'S HAS PROVED.
THAT THEY'RE OVERLY CUMBERSOME
TO ESTABLISH AND OPERATE. WITH
THE HOUSING CRISIS RAVAGING
CITIES AND COUNTIES ACROSS THE
STATE THE REBELS ISSUE THESE
TOOLS AS WELL OVER DUE. SB
SEVEN EIGHTY MAKE SEVERAL
CHANGES TO YEAH- IF P. AND C.
R. I. A LAW THAT WILL ENABLE
LOCAL AGENCIES TO USE THESE
TOOLS TO EFFECTIVELY STIMULATE
DEVELOPMENT IN THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. AMONG OTHER
IMPORTANT CHANGES THE BILL
STREAMLINES THE PROCESS FOR
AMENDING THE EXISTING PLANTS
AND REWRITES THE TENURE
PROTEST. PROCESS IN THE C. R.
I. A LAW. TO MAKE C. R. A.'S AN
E. I. F.THESE MORE VIABLE FOR
LOCAL AGENCIES TO CREATE AND
OPERATE. THIS BILL PASSED A
SENATE HOUSING THE GOVERNANCE
OF FINANCE COMMITTEE WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR CORTESE
MEMBERS. DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI AT
KINS I PLEASE. BACKER HI FORGES.
BRADFORD I HAVE A- CORTESE HI
SALLY. DOT. FIVE TORONTO HI
ADNAN FIVE BLAZER FIVE DOLLARS
FIVE GROWTH. HI HURTS BERG FIVE
WEST SO. HI HER TADO. HI JOE. I
CANNOT I LAYERED HI LATER HI
MICHAEL. HI MELINDA. FIVE MEN
FIVE NEWMAN HI NIELSEN HI A
CHOKE HI PAM HI. HI ROB HI
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. HI I'M BERG
HI WHAT KASKY HI WINNER ALL
RIGHT HI WILKE HI HI. THANK YOU
SECRETARY. FIVE THIRTY FOUR.
PLEASE CALL THE OF THE MEMBERS.
FACE. FORGES. BY ADAM. DALLY AS
THE REPORT MOVES ZERO
DEPARTMENT- THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS ARE READY TO FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN SENATOR ARCHULETA.
WHEN THE SECRETARY READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY
THREE BY SENATOR ARCHULETA
RELATIVE TO FOOD ALLERGY
AWARENESS WEEK CENTER CHULA.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY THREE WHICH DECLARES THE
WEEK OF MAY TENTH TO THE MAY
SIXTEENTH AT FOOD ALLERGY
AWARENESS WEEK. RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT FOOD ALLERGIES ARE
INCREASING IN CHILDREN AND
ADULTS THROUGHOUT THE UNITED
STATES AND IT IS INCUMBENT UPON
US AS LEGISLATORS TO SUPPORT
INCREASED AWARENESS OF FOOD
ALLERGIES SO WE CAN SAVE LIVES.
FOOD ALLERGY REACTIONS ARE
DIFFERENT FOR EVERYONE SOME CAN
BE A MILD SOME CAN BE SO SEVERE
THAT THEY JUST SEND SOMEONE TO
THE EMERGENCY ROOM. IN FACT
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE A YEAR AFTER VISIT
HOSPITAL IMMEDIATE MEDICAL
INTERVENTION AFTER UNKNOWINGLY
EATING FOOD CONTAINING AN
INGREDIENT TO WHICH THEY ARE
NURTURED. NINE FOODS THAT ARE
KNOWN TO CAUSE THE MAJORITY OF
ALL FOOD ALLERGY REACTIONS
INCLUDE SHELLFISH FOOD- FRESH
MILK FISH MILK EGGS TREE NUTS
PEANUTS SOY SOY WHEAT AND
SESAME. MOREOVER THESE FOODS
CAN BE FOUND IN JUST ABOUT
EVERY KITCHEN IN AMERICA
ALLERGIC REACTIONS ARE SO
WIDESPREAD THAT INCREASED
AWARENESS IS NECESSARY IN ORDER
TO KEEP PACE WITH INCREASED
INCIDENCE LEVELS I AM HAPPY TO
REPORT THAT JUST RECENTLY THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. PRESIDENT BIDEN
SIGNED INTO LAW THE FOOD
ALLERGY SAFETY TREATMENT
EDUCATION AND RESEARCH ACT OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. ALSO KNOWN
AS THE FASTER AT. THE FASTER
ACT REQUIRES THAT SAYS TO BE.
CLEARLY LABELED ON PACKAGED
FOODS BEGINNING JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND THAT
FOOD ALLERGY RESEARCH BE GIVEN
GREATER PRIORITY BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. THIS IS A GREAT
FIRST STEP. BUT FOOD ALLERGIES
ARE VERY SERIOUS AND NEED OUR
CONTINUED ATTENTION FOR THESE
REASONS I ASKED TO JOIN ME IN
SUPPORT OF S. C. R. THIRTY
THREE AND COMMIT TO INCREASING
AWARENESS AROUND THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR ARCHULETA MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THAT IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING OUR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING THEM FIVE THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE'RE NOW MOVING TO FILE ITEM
NINETEEN SENATOR ROBERT ARE YOU
PREPARED TO PRESENT. HAVE FUN
FOR A VERY GOOD WE'RE GONNA GO
TO FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE SENATOR
DODD NOT AT HIS DESK FOLLOW HIM
TWENTY THREE SENATOR CORTESE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL FOUR ELEVEN BY
SENATOR CORTEZ HE'S AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT CENTER CORTESE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT TURN.
HELLO COLLEAGUES AND I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT SP FOUR
ELEVEN THE WORK AFTER
RETIREMENT ACT SB FOUR ELEVEN
WILLOW CALPERS STAFF TO WORK
WITH RETIRED MEMBERS AND
EMPLOYERS TO RESOLVE WORKING
AFTER RETIREMENT VIOLATIONS IN
AN EFFICIENT AND AGREEABLE
MANNER. EXISTING LAWS A CALPERS
RETIREE TO RETURN TO WORK WITH
THE CALPERS EMPLOYER UNDER
CERTAIN LIMITATIONS. THESE
RETIREES ARE ALSO KNOWN AS A
RETIRED AND DO IT TONIGHT AND
THEY WERE LIMITED TO NINE
HUNDRED SIXTY HOURS OF WORK PER
YEAR. SOME RETURN RETIREES DO
THIS TO SUPPLEMENT THEIR
RETIREMENT INCOME FOR OTHERS
FEEL IN A SENSUAL VACANCIES
DURING AN EMERGENCY TO ENSURE
ADEQUATE STAFFING FOR ME
TEMPORARILY STUFF THEY CAN
POSITIONS WHEN NEEDED.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY OF THESE
RETIREES ARE CURRENTLY FACING
SIGNIFICANT COMPOUNDING
PENALTIES FOR UNINTENTIONALLY
GOING OVER THEIR CURRENT
LIMITATION OF NINE HUNDRED
SIXTY HOURS FOR INSTANCE. THEY
WEREN'T AWARE OF THIS IMITATION
OR THE EMPLOYER MAY HAVE AN
OVERLY MISINFORM THEM SP FOUR
ELEVEN WOULD SIMPLY GRAB THE
CALPERS BOARD THE AUTHORITY TO
WAIVE OR REDUCE FINES FOR THOSE
RETIREES. THE INDIFFERENT LEGAL
OVER THE NINETEEN NINE HUNDRED
SIXTY HOUR LIMIT. BASED ON THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND CONDITIONS OF
THAT PARTICULAR VIOLATION
WITHOUT HAVING TO FORCE A
RETIREE TO REINSTATE BACK INTO
THE SYSTEM. THIS WILL PUT AN
END TO WHAT IN SOME CASES CAN
AMOUNT TO AN EGREGIOUS
ENCUMBRANCE ON RETIREES FROM
COMPOUNDING. AND INCREASE
PENALTIES AND INSTEAD ALLOW FOR
RESOLUTIONS. TO THESE
UNINTENTIONAL VIOLATIONS. FOR
RETIREES TO A- PIECE OF MY- IN
A SENSE IS A- FOR THE FUTURE.
AS IT CAN TO CAN TOWARDS SCHOOL
AND PUBLIC AGENCIES. ESPECIALLY
DURING TIMES SOCIAL TURMOIL.
LIKE TO KNOW THE SPONSORING
THIS BILL IS A CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
INCLUDES THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT SYSTEM
CALPERS ALONG WITH OTHERS.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR ARRIVAL. THANK YOU
SENATOR CORTESE MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING THEM FIVE THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE SENATOR
DODD MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTY
NINE BY SENATOR DODD AND I
ACTUALLY WENT TO A COLLEGE THAT
BRIDGES. SENATOR DODD MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AS ALL OF YOU
ARE AWARE EARLY LAST YEAR THE
DEPARTMENT ABC PROVIDING
REGULATORY RELIEF FOR ALCOHOL
LICENSES BY ALLOWING
RESTAURANTS THE ABILITY TO SELL
BOTH PRE PACKAGED ALCOHOLIC
DRINKS IN PRE MIXED DRINKS TO
CUSTOMERS AS PART OF THEIR TO
GO MEALS ORDER SP THREE EIGHTY
NINE BUILDS UPON THE REGULATORY
RELIEF BY ALLOWING THE HOLDER
OF AN ON SALE RETAIL LICENSE
WHICH INCLUDES RESTAURANTS AND
BARS THE ABILITY TO SELL BOTH
PRE PACKAGED ALCOHOLIC DRINKS
IT PRE MIXED DRINKS FOR
CONSUMPTION OFF. THE LICENSED
PREMISES THIS BILL INCLUDES A
NUMBER OF SAFEGUARDS THAT WERE
NOT INCLUDED IN THE REGULATORY
RELIEF FOR EXAMPLE THIS BILL
REQUIRES THE CUT CONTAINER BE
SEALED IN A MANNER THAT IS
DESIGNED TO PREVENT CONSUMPTION
WITHOUT THE BREAKING OF THE
SEAL IT ALSO REQUIRES
CONTAINERS TO BE CLEARLY
LABELED OR OTHERWISE IDENTIFIED
AS CONTAINING ALCOHOL THE
SAFEGUARDS ARE DESIGNED TO HELP
LAW ENFORCEMENT IT CLEARLY
IDENTIFY THESE CONTAINERS TO
EASILY DETERMINE IF AN
INDIVIDUAL IS BROKEN THE SEAL.
I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR THAT
NOTHING IN THIS BILL CHANGES
ANY LAWS RELATING TO DRINKING
AND DRIVING- IN PUBLIC THERE'S
NOTHING THAT'S BILL FORCES AT
LICENSEES TO DO THE BILL AS
RECEIVED NO NOTES BOATS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I HAVE A-
THE CENTER DOT MEMBERS THE DISK.
AT OR- SEEING AND HEARING THEM
IS THERE ANY OBJECT TO USING A
UNIT ROLE. SEEING HER THEM FIVE
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSED. RIVERS REMOVING TO FIVE
ITEM. CENTER- NUMBER MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. THANK
BILL THIRTY FIVE BY SENATOR
UMBERG AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS SENATOR UMBERG. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR IN MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS OF THE
ELECTION IN NOVEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE EXTREMELY WELL HERE
IN CALIFORNIA THERE WERE A
COUPLE ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED HOWEVER- ONE IS
ELECTION NEARING NEAR THE
POLLING PLACE TOO IS THE
PLACEMENT OF BOXES WITH THE
TITLE OFFICIAL ON THEM WHICH
WEREN'T OFFICIAL DROP BOXES.
AND THREE ELECTIONEERING NEAR-
DROP BOXES WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS IT EXTENDS THE- DISTANCE.
WHERE YOU CAN ELECTION HERE
FROM ONE HUNDRED TO TWO HUNDRED
FEET IT PROHIBITS LECTURING IN
AROUND DROP BOXES AND ALSO
PROHIBITS UP PLACING THE TERM
OFFICIAL ON A DROP BOX IT'S NOT
OFFICIAL ORIGIN I VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR NUMBER MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA. FIVE ACTIONS
I BASE. BACKER I FORGES.
BRADFORD I COULD BUY A- COURT.
I DALLY. DOT HI THE RUSSELL HI
ADNAN I BELIEVE. HI GONZALEZ HI
GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI WITH SO.
HI HER TADO HI JOAN. NO CAN
LONGER HI. I LIVE. I WIRE. I
WILL. MAN FIVE NEWMAN I NIELSEN.
I CHOSE BOTH. HI PAN FIVE FORTY
TINO. HI ROSS I GREW. HI
SKINNER. HI AMBERG FIVE SKI I
WINNER. HI. YEAH NOW PLEASE
CALL THE OF THE MEMBERS. BABIES
BARGE. BY ADAM. DALLY GROVE.
MALIGNED YEAH NIELSEN. FIVE
NINE NEWS TO THE MEASURE OVER
FOR ME TO FALL HIM 26% A MAN
SHE'S METAPHYSIC PLEASE READ.
SEND BILL FIVE SIXTEEN BY
SENATOR ADMIN AND I RELATING TO
POKE SOCIAL SERVICE CENTER
AYMAN. THE YOU VERY MUCH TODAY
I PRESENT SP FIVE C. A BILL
THAT I THINK WILL ACT AS A
NARROWING IN SPECIFIC
IMPROVEMENT TO OUR MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM. UNDER CURRENT
LAW A PERSON EXPERIENCE A
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS CAN BE
HELD FOR TREATMENT
INVOLUNTARILY F THEY MEET
CERTAIN CRITERIA. TYPICALLY WE
THINK ABOUT THIS IS A FIFTY ONE
FIFTY AND IT PROVIDES WITH THE
SEVENTY TWO HOUR HOLD THEY
COULD THEN BE RELEASED OR
HEARING CAN BE HELD TO
DETERMINE WHETHER CONDITION
REQUIRES ADDITIONAL AND
INTENSIVE CARE. UNDER THIS BILL
A HEARING OFFICER WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO CONSIDER
INFORMATION REQUIRING A
PRISON'S MEDICAL CONDITION AND
HOW THAT CONDITION BEARS ON THE
CERTIFICATION OF WHETHER THEY
ARE A DANGER TO THEMSELVES
GRAVELY DISABLED WHEN THE
TURNING. TO CONTINUE HOLD. FOR
THE ADDITIONAL TREATMENT. WITH
A MIDDLE HEALTH ISSUE BLACK
PASS TO BUY FOR THE BASE NEEDS
OF. CLOTHING AND SHELTER. THE
LAW CONSIDERS THEM GRAVELY
DISABLED ALLOWS TREATMENT OVER
ANY OBJECTIONS TO STABILIZE
THEIR MENTAL ILLNESS. RESTORE
CAPACITY AND REDUCE THE RISK
OF. SELF HARM. UNDER CURRENT
HOWEVER CURRENT LAW FAILS TO
ADDRESS INDIVIDUALS WITH A
MENTAL. ILLNESS WHO LACKED THE
PASSION TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR
MEDICAL NEEDS. THAT'S B. FIVE
SIXTEEN INCLUDE SPECIFIC
CRITERIA REGARDING THE DANGERS
OF THE CONDITION AND THE
PROGNOSIS OF HARM WITHIN SIX
MONTHS ALONG WITH ADDITIONAL
PROTECTIONS. TO BE CLEAR
NOTHING IN THIS BILL ALLOWS
DRAMATIC MANDATED MEDICAL
TREATMENT. IT ONLY SEEKS TO
RESTORE AN INDIVIDUAL'S
CAPACITY TO CARE FOR THEIR
SERIOUS MEDICAL NEEDS. THIS
BILL I BELIEVE CAN HELP PEOPLE
STRIKES A BALANCE BETWEEN
PROTECTING. VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AND PROTECTING
PERSONAL BREAKS THIS BILL
PASSED POLICY COMMITTEES WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR IGMAN MEMBERS.
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE. C.
AND HEARING THAT BETTER. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
HI AT KINS. HI BASED. BACKER HI
GORGEOUS. BRADFORD I HAVE A-
CORTESE HI DALLY. I DON. HI
TORONTO HI ADNAN HI GLAZER. HI
GONZALEZ HI GROSS HI HURTS BERG
FIVE WITH SO HI TADO HI JONES
HI LOG HI LAYERED I LIVE. HI
MCGUIRE. HI MELINDA'S. MEN I
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. HI BY A SHOW
OF BOTH I PAM HI FOURTEEN TINA.
HI ROTH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER HI
NUMBER HI WHAT KIND OF SKI HI
WINNER I WILL. HI PLEASE CALL
THE HELP THE MEMBERS. FACE
PORGES. BY ADAM. MELINDA'S.
FIVE THREE FOUR NINE ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES NUMBER THREE ON
THE FILE AND TWENTY SEVEN
SENATOR DODD MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FIVE
SIXTY ONE BY SENATOR DODD AN
ACT RELATING TO ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES CENTERED ON WHEELS.
MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS THIS
BILL SIMPLY ALLOWS ALCOHOL
MANUFACTURERS TO SHARE A COMMON
AREA WITH MULTIPLE READ
RETAILERS RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. I THANK YOU SENATOR DODD
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM BY
THIRTY SEVEN NINE ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY EIGHT SENATOR
HERTZBERG MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FIVE
SEVENTY TWO BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG AN ACT RELATING TO
EMPLOYMENT SENATOR HERTZBERG.
HI MADAM PRESIDENT- THIS
MEASURE IT EXPEDITES THE
PROCESS FOR FILING LIENS TO
ENFORCE FINAL JUDGMENTS THAT
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE
ELIMINATES THE STEP STEP OF
GETTING AN ABSTRACT OF JUDGMENT
WHICHTAKES A LOT OF TIME AND
ALLOWS FOR FOLKS- WE'RE TRYING
TO AVOID LIABILITY TO SKATE
THAT LIABILITY IT'S INTELLIGENT
EXPEDITING THE PROCESS FOR MY
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG MEMBERS DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE. THING IN EVERY
MAN THAT SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. HI ARCHULETA. I.
ATKINS. I BASE HI BECKER HI FOR
JUST. HI BRADFORD. BY ADAM.
CORTESE HI DALLY I DON. HI
TORONTO HI ADNAN I BELIEVE-
FIVE GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH. HI
HURTS BERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA HI WIRE I%
MELINDA'S I MEN. HI NEWMAN R.
I. NIELSEN. A CHILL OF BOTH. HI
PAM HI FORTUNE TINO. I. ROSS HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER. HI AMBERG
FIVE BY CASSIDY HI WINNER HI
WELL I WILL BE ABSENT MEMBER.
BRADFORD HI. BY ADAM. NIELSEN
FIVE THIRTY THREE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE MEMBERS REMEMBER ON TO
FOR ITEM TWENTY SENATOR ARE
ALETTA MEN SECRETARY READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE SEVENTY SIX BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA AN ACT
RELATING TO GAMBLING CENTER
CHULA. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL FIVE SEVEN
SIX WHICH CONTINUES A SERIES OF
MORATORIUMS AND CARD CLUB
EXPANSIONS AND THE SAME TIME
ALLOWS FOR MODEST GROWTH.
CALIFORNIA CARD CLUBS ARE
FUNDAMENTAL **** TO MANY LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. SOME EVEN SERVICE
THE LARGEST SINGLE SOURCE OF
TAX REVENUE FOR THE CITY IN
WHICH THEY'RE LOCATED. CARDROOM
TAXES FUND ESSENTIAL PUBLIC
SAFETY AND HEALTH SERVICES
INCLUDING FUNDING FOR PARKS
WATER DELIVERY AND
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS. GUARD
ROOMS ARE ALSO THEY ALSO
GENERATE SIGNIFICANT EMPLOYMENT
AND SECONDARY BUSINESS
ACTIVITIES IN MANY COMMUNITIES.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY FIVE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
EXERCISED ITS AUTHORITY TO
IMPOSE MORATORIUMS ON THE
EXPANSION OF GAMING. WITH THE
LAST EXTENSION OF THE
MORATORIUM BEING PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY THIRTEEN.
pALSO ALLOWED FOR REASONABLE
INCREASES IN THE NUMBER OF
TABLES A LOCAL GOVERNMENT COULD
PERMIT AND A CARD ROOM. THE
CURRENT MORATORIUM ON COURT
ROOM EXPANSION THE SET TO
SUNSET JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. FURTHERMORE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS NOT INCREASED
THE NUMBER OF TABLES THAT MAYBE
LOCALLY APPROVED IN EXISTING
CARD ROOM SINCE TWENTY
THIRTEEN. TO ENSURE STABILITY
AND TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
REVENUE OPPORTUNITIES THIS BILL
WILL EXTEND THE CURRENT
MORATORIUM TO JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT AND ALLOW A
MODEST INCREASE IN TABLES AT
EXISTING CARD CLUBS. TO BE
SPECIFIC THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
SUBJECT TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
APPROVAL UP TO TWO TABLES FOR
YEAR WITH A MAXIMUM OF TEN
ADDITIONAL TABLES. IN TURN THIS
BILL WILL PROVIDE NEEDED
FINANCIAL STABILITY TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT RELY ON
REVENUE FROM LICENSED GAMING.
THIS BILL REPRESENTS A
COMPROMISE BETWEEN CONTINUING
THE CARD ROOM MORATORIUM AND
ALLOWING FOR MODEST GROWTH FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER ARCHULETA MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA FIVE ADKINS
HI BABIES HI BECKER FIVE
GORGEOUS. BRADFORD HI CAN I GET
A- CORTESE HI DALLY FIVE DODD.
I COMMEND HI GLAZER. FIVE TEN
DOLLARS HIGH GROWTH. HERTZBERG
HI WITH SO. HI HER TADO HI
JONES. CAN LONGER FIVE LAYERED
HI LLEVA HI WIRE HI MELINDA'S.
MAN FIVE NEWMAN. NIELSEN BY A
SHOW OF BOTH. NO PAN HI FORTUNE
TINO. HI RALPH. HI RUBIO. HI
SKINNER FIVE NUMBER HI WHAT
KIND O SKI I WINNER FIVE WELL
NO PLEASE CALL THE HELP THE
MEMBERS. FORTUS BY ADAM. GROVE
JONES. MELINDA'S NEWMAN. FIVE
THIRTY NOSE TO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON
THE FILE AND I'M THIRTY THREE
CENTER CORTESE HAREM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN
OH SEVEN BY SENATOR CORTEZ SEE
AN ACT RELATING TO CONTINUING
CARE CONTRACTS AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE CENTER
CORTESE THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT S. B.
SEVEN OH SEVEN. S. B. SEVEN OH
SEVEN WILL PROVIDE CURRENT
FUTURE RESIDENTS OF CONTINUING
pCARE RETIREMENT COMMUNITIES
WITH A SENSE OF SECURITY
REGARDING THE SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL COMMITMENT THEY MAKE
RETURN FOR LIFELONG HOME AND
HEALTH CARE- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
SENATOR CORTESE MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
EMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
SEEING AND HEARING THEM FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FOR MOVING ONTO
FILE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT ALSO
CENTER CORTESE. M. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SIX
FORTY NINE BY SENATOR CORTEZ
SEE AN ACT RELATING TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CENTER
CORTESE THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM
PRESIDENT- BEGIN GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
SP SIX FORTY NINE A BILL THAT
ALIGNS TENANT PREFERENCES WITH
INTERNAL REVENUE CODE
REQUIREMENTS TO ALLOW HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS USE TAX CREDIT OR
BOND FINANCING TO REDUCE
DISPLACEMENT BY USING TENET
PREFERENCES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
CENTER CORTESE MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
AND HEARING THEM FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE I'M THIRTY NINE
SENATOR ALAN. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY BY SENATOR
ALAN RELATIVE TO ARTS CULTURE
AND CREATIVITY MONTHS. ALAN THE
MORNING AT A PRESENT MEMBERS
THIS RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANT
ROLE OF CREATIVE WORKERS AND
ARTISTS THE SECOND RESPONDERS
CELEBRATES APRIL AS ARTS
CULTURE AND CREATIVITY MONTHLY
CALIFORNIA PLEASE JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANT ROLE
OF CREATIVE WORKERS A SECOND
RESPONDERS IN OUR STATE. I
ASKED HER ABOUT. THANK YOU
SENATOR ALAN MEMBERS DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING THEN IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL SEEING AND HEARING
THEN I WAS THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY ONE
SENATOR GLAZER. BEN SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO BY SENATOR GLAZER AN
ACT RELATING TO MENTAL HEALTH
CENTER PLEASE OR THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS
BILL WOULD IMPLEMENT
RECOMMENDATIONS BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR- AND
THE WORK THAT THEY DID TO
REVIEW OUR STATE MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM- THE BILL AND ALICE'S
DETAILS THE IMPORTANT CHANGES
THAT IT WOULD MAKE. I WANT TO
THANK- MY COLLEAGUES HERE IN
THE SENATE SENATOR RUBIO AND
MENENDEZ FOR THEIR CO
SPONSORSHIP THE BILL PASSED OUT
OF. HEALTH AND YOU JUST YOUR
UNANIMOUSLY WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASTRONOMICAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZER
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING MEN
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ALL
EYES THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE'RE
NOW GOING TO MOVE TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SENATE JOINT
RESOLUTION THREE SENATE BILLS.
FIVE NINETY ONE FIFTY EIGHT TO
FOURTEEN TO EIGHTY ONE THREE
THIRTY THREE THREE SIXTY SEVEN
THREE EIGHTY FOUR FOR FORTY ONE
FOR SIXTY EIGHT FOUR EIGHTY
SEVEN FIVE OH FIVE FIVE FORTY
ONE FIVE EIGHTY ONE FIVE NINETY
NINE SIX THIRTY EIGHT SIX
NINETY FOUR SEVEN OH ONE SEVEN
OH NINE. 350-881-5819 EIGHT
TWENTY ONE. EIGHT TWENTY TWO
EIGHT TWENTY THREE EIGHT TWENTY
FOUR AND SENATE BILL EIGHT
TWENTY FIVE CENT CONNECTS
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SEVEN. TWELVE FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
TWENTY FOUR SENATE BILLS SIX
SIXTEEN. THREE FORTY FOUR
THIRTY TWO AND SENATE BILL TWO
ELEVEN. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY MEMBERS BEFORE WE
VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR TO
ANYONE WANT TO REMOVE ANYTHING
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR. A
GOOD BIT OF SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I BASE HI
BECKER I PORCHES HI BRADFORD I
HAVE A I DON'T. PROTESTING HI
DALLY I DON HI TORONTO HI ADNAN
FIVE GLAZER HI DOLLARS FIVE
GROSS. HI HERTZBERG I WAS SO.
HI HER TADO HI JONES I CAN
LONGER. I LAYERED I LLEVA I
REQUIRE. I MELINDA'S. FIVE MEN
HI NEWMAN I NELSON I HAVE A
SHOW OF BOTH HI PAM HI FORTUNE
TINO. FIVE ROTH HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER. HI AMBER I HI MY
CUSTODY FIVE WINNER I WILL HI.
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS BEEN
ADOPTED MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING
BACK TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
SENATOR MELINDA'S. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN ONCE AGAIN I AM
MAKING A MOTION TO WITHDRAW S.
C. R. FIVE FROM THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE AND HAVE IT BROUGHT
TO THE SENATE FLOOR SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE A FULL AND VIGOROUS
DEBATE. ABOUT THE CONTINUED
MERITS OF THE GOVERNOR'S STATE
OF EMERGENCY. EVERY CALIFORNIAN
OVER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN CAN
NOW GET A COVERT VACCINE IF
THEY SO CHOOSE. THE GOVERNOR
ANNOUNCED THAT ON JUNE
FIFTEENTH THE STATE WILL FULLY
RE OPEN AND THERE'S BEEN FOUR
HUNDRED DAYS SINCE THE GOVERNOR
DECLARED A STATE OF EMERGENCY
PER CABIN. AND SHUT DOWN THE
STATE AND SINCE THIS DECORATE
DECLARATION OUR ROLE AS
LEGISLATORS HAS CLEARLY
DIMINISHED. IF THE CRISIS IS
INDEED OVER THERE'S NO LONGER A
NEED FOR THE STATE OF THE
EMERGENCY. AND SINCE IT HAS
BEEN FOUR HUNDRED DAYS THE
POWER IS DEEMED TO HAVE BEEN
TEMPORARY HAVE NOW LASTED OVER
A YEAR WITH THAT SAID I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE. TO ALLOW S. SIERRA FIVE
TO BE HEARD THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SENATOR
MELINDA'S SENATOR HURTS FOR
PURPOSE YOUR RIGHTS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT WITH RESPECT TO
THIS MOTION WITHDRAWS THE
MAJORITY LEADER ASKED FOR A NO
VOTE PLEASE. THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG CENTER MELINDA'S IS
ASKING FOR AN I'VE HEARD FIVE
VOTE THE MAJORITY LEADER IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN NO ARCHULETA. NO ATKINS.
NO FACE. HI BACKER. NO FORTUS
HI BRADFORD NOPE I GOTTA.
CORTEZ C. O. NO DALLY HI TODD
NO THERE ARE ALSO NO ADMIN NO
GLAZER. NO GONZALEZ NO GROWTH
FIVE HERTZBERG. NO WAY SO. YOU
KNOW HER TADO. JONES I CAN
LONGER NO LAYERED NO LLEVA NO
MCGUIRE NO MELINDA'S I MEN.
NOPE NEWMAN NO NIELSEN HI A
CHILL OF BOTH. I CAN NO FORTINO.
NO ROTH. NO RUBIO NO SKINNER NO
AMBERG NO WHITE HOUSE SKI. NO
WINNER NO WELL HI FIVE NINE
NEWS TWENTY SEVENTH OF MAY
MOTION TO WITHDRAW FAILS
MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS CENTERS GET. THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WILL MEET HERE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS UPON
ADJOURNMENT AFTER THE CLEANING.
AFTER THE CLEAN THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER IF THERE IS NO
FURTHER BUSINESS SENATOR ATKINS
THE DESK IS CLEAR. MAN
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR THE
WORK TODAY OUR NEXT FLOOR
SESSION WILL BE SCHEDULED FOR
THIS THURSDAY MAY THIRTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT NINE AM
THANK YOU THANK YOU MAN
APPROACHED HIM THE SENATE WILL
BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY
PM AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE. WE WILL RECONVENE
THURSDAY AT NINE AM HAVE A
GREAT REST OF THE MEMBERS.